tonight on et canada
hey it's mike boops
i go one-on-one with michael buble
the canadian crooner gets candid about
his new album i've made the greatest
music of my life his marriage many times
i'm sure both of us looked at each other
and thought is this the right thing i
know there's a part of you
that's terrified
again
and his upcoming stint in vegas it's
gonna be a blast then michael reveals
which a-list collaboration rocked his
world it's my favorite duet like ever
it's my favorite
[Music]
plus he shares his surprising celebrity
crush i mean i would go further than
that i would leave my wife
okay
this is e.t canada
welcome to a special edition of et
canada i'm cheryl hickey tonight we go
one on one with our good friend michael
buble the iconic canadian crooner is
celebrating the release of haier his
11th studio album and our conversation
covers everything from new music to
marriage to parenthood plus so much more
but first it's all about a-list
collaborations yes michael worked with
some pretty big stars on this new record
including
sir paul mccartney
my valentine
one of the co-producers on this album is
sir paul mccartney on the song by
valentine what was it like being in
studio with him it was amazing and it
was so cool you know what's funny is
that everyone said how did you get him
but
i didn't get him he called us his his
manager scott called yeah and said we
know you're making a record and paul
thinks that you would do this song
really great and i said
to my manager i said jesus bruce you
know it would be even better if paul
could produce it i'd tell myself that i
was waiting for
a sign
i sent a demo of it that i'd done with
this wonderful arranger and i got a call
back from the uk number and i said hello
and this man said oh it's it's paul mack
he said
and i said hey it's mike boobs
no you didn't you didn't that's exactly
what i said and he was so sweet what if
it rained
we didn't care
he had written that for his wife and
[Music]
they'd gone to the hamptons for a
holiday and felt guilty because it was
raining and kid basically said who cares
if it rains you know we have each other
so there was this emotional depth for it
and as a producer we all know that paul
mccartney is a talented man but great
producer really warm generous
great with everybody in the room it was
a big session too because we had
nearly a hundred or more musicians and i
sang it live off the floor and paul was
the lone man in the studio
who is the best reaction to you saying
that you were going to be doing this
with paul mccartney me i had the best
reaction yeah because on that same phone
call
when he said he would do it
yeah i i
i i
didn't know what to do so i just i just
started to punch my fist in there and i
was quiet about it and then he thought
he lost me he said hello hello
are you still there and i said yes he
said oh i thought i lost you i said no i
was just pooping my pants is what i said
so you you told them you're pooping your
pants and you called and he said he said
he said
in the driest way he said oh don't do
that he said
from a pop rock icon to a country music
legend there's no shortage of incredible
collaborations on michael's new album
higher
[Music]
willie nelson is on the song crazy how
did that come about did you reach out to
him or did he call you too i've been
friends with lucas who's willie's son
for a few years and
i've always just shared my reverence
people may not
get because they might not think of
willie that way but when i think of the
greatest crooners of all time frank and
dean and tony bennett willie's always
been up there on my list and i
was always in love and it's funny
everyone knows crazy and they know what
to be patsy klein's song but that's not
the version i loved i loved willy's
which was the original that he wrote and
that was his first single and so i had
this idea to do it with him and just
hearing him play the guitar and stuff
and like getting to hang and just the
coolest dude in the universe and um
that's incredible it's my favorite duet
like ever it's my favorite really and
i'll come in here
and i knew
you'd love me as long
as you wanted
you have so many celebrity friends and
connections your publicist also works
with madonna and cher would you duet
with them together like the three of you
[Music]
come together
um
sometime to think of what what that
would be it would be incredible i think
i was very close to working with cher
just a little while ago we were gonna do
uh yeah there was a thing we were there
was a christmas thing or something i was
doing and it didn't happen i don't know
hallelujah
[Music]
yeah that's higher the title track off
michael buble's brand new studio album
and tonight's hot shot takes us behind
the scenes of the music video and
believe it or not dancing with the stars
alum derek huff is the man behind these
incredible visuals using the hashtag the
bromance is real there praised his
frequent collaborator on instagram
saying he had the pleasure of directing
michael buble's newest video higher when
i first heard the song my jaw hit the
floor
speaking of jaw-dropping collabs juno
host and shangshi star simulio told us
he's hoping to share the stage with
michael at this year's general awards in
toronto
[Music]
marvel star single leo
told us he really would love to sing
with you i would love to surprise
michael douglas
with one of his own songs
[Music]
now if he puts you in a marvel movie
would you do it would you wear the tight
tights and do all the training
and what would your superpower be
because i just want to know my ears
might let me fly
like dumbo remember that
so they just stick a feather in my mouth
and just believe it you can do it boob
like it's not the feather it's your big
ears
all kidding aside michael is a huge fan
of simu and his blockbuster hit
is this what you wanted
i have to tell you i didn't know he was
canadian
and i just found out and i was
so excited i thought it was a great
movie and i thought he was great
i thought i could change my name
start a new life
but he wants to sing with you do you
want to
do i want to be with him yeah
i want to be
i mean i would go further than that
i would leave my wife if it came
okay okay all right well and did you see
his body when he took up his shirt
i might have looked i might have left i
might have seen that
i didn't look i wasn't looking i was
memorizing for later
[Music]
i also know that you worked with ryan
tetter from one republic who's written
for adele taylor swift beyonce i know
he's a perfectionist so my question is
are you a perfectionist now and and how
are you at taking criticism constructive
criticism from others why what are you
saying something wrong with me oh here
we go
[Music]
of course i am it's it's of course i am
i'm an artist and
and i have a hard time leaving things be
ryan tedder is a really close a great
friend i just saw him yesterday actually
listen i walked into that studio never
having really hung out with ryan i
walked away with a hit song
a wonderful lifelong friendship and i
gained about 12 pounds because he kept
bringing chick-fil-a to the writing
sessions and i didn't know what
chick-fil-a was i think
[Applause]
it is ridiculously good
and
it's hard to keep the weight up
it's messing with my mind the lead
single is called i'll never stop loving
you which i can only imagine is about
your beautiful wife lou two little tiny
corrections number one is the song is
called i'll never not love you that's
okay
and number two i didn't for my wife i
wrote it actually for chick-fil-a
okay fried chicken is michael's
kryptonite who knew coming up michael
and his wife lou have a huge surprise to
share with us i'll give you a hint it
was recently revealed in his new music
video stay with us
i'm not kidding i made a music video the
likes you've never seen
[Music]
leave you
behind
melting my heart that is michael buble
serenading his daughter turning his hit
single i'll never not love you into a
beautiful lullaby clearly michael is the
ultimate dad and good thing too because
he and his wife lou recently announced
that they are expanding their family
once again in the most amazing way
possible i just haven't met you yet
how it started
this is how it's going
yes michael buble and his wife lucana
are expecting baby number four
dropping their big baby surprise in a
new video i'll never not love you
and michael confirmed the exciting news
to on air with ryan seacrest this will
be the first time that i actually
say these words but yes my wife and i
are
grateful to be expected oh my gosh buble
and his wife pay tribute to hollywood's
timeless love stories but save the very
best for last of course i'm not kidding
i made a music video the likes you've
never seen it is me
and my wife
going through our favorite scenes in
cinematic history you guys were doing
the notebook thing right basically i
think what i've done is given my wife
the fantasy she's always dreamed of yes
tonight i'm going home
it wasn't over
still isn't over
it's so good and everybody told me not
to do it everybody said why are you
doing this this is ambitious you're
gonna you can't it's too much
all this stuff and i was like this song
is so good i'm gonna have a hit song
that's what i kept saying i'm gonna have
a hit song and it's been a long time
since i've had a big stinking hit and
this song deserves
the vehicle of this music video it is
it's so good
but of course their baby announcement
pays tribute to michael's 2009 hit
haven't met you yet and only we were on
set while michael gushed about his then
girlfriend lou your girlfriend's in the
music video
how fun is that it was so much fun
what's weird is that um i mean the song
was inspired by her so
and it was and she's a great actor the
happy couple have been married since
2011 and have three beautiful kids but
they've certainly experienced their fair
share of ups and downs i thought my wife
was the most beautiful woman i'd ever
seen in my life but i didn't know her i
was infatuated by her and then we got
married and even then
it was still pretty early i mean
many times i'm sure both of us looked at
each other and thought
you know
it was just the right thing
and then we had our first child and
and our second
and then when that thing happened with
noah
and we found out
who we had really married
i think that's when we fell in love
back in 2016 their son noah was
diagnosed with liver cancer say hello
e.t canada hello e.t canada
my wife and i and our family don't know
that people will ever understand that we
know we're not the only family that's
gone through hard things and uh not only
did we we know that there were people
that were sending us messages of love
that there were people
in their churches and synagogues and
temples all over the world praying for
us
you know i want other
[Music]
other parents to know that there's
there's hope and then
even when there's not
somehow it's going to be okay
thankfully noah is now in remission you
know what when the poop hits the fan you
find out who you're dealing with
absolutely and i think i think both of
us you know
looked at each other and went wow this
was we got really lucky here i think
you're right when life does what it does
and you have something where you both
either dig in or you get out which is
what a lot of couples do right
that's where you either fall back in
love and you really go for it
or
circumstances break you up it's been
something it's been quite a journey and
i'm a
i'm a big fan
[Music]
would you ever consider doing a duet
with lou maybe one day i don't i don't
know whatever i do with her i want it to
be organic
i mean their chemistry is undeniable
fingers crossed we'll get that duet on
the next album stick around because
michael still has more to share
including details surrounding his
upcoming stint in vegas which i hope to
be at all right we'll be right back it's
going to be a blast
[Music]
i
have been trying so hard not to
mix up who i am with what i do and
trying to make sure that things aren't
results driven and so
i
i think i found great joy in realizing
that this was
this opportunity to share
that accolade with all of these
beautiful people and to them to look out
and see my wife and to see my mom and
dad and to see foster all of these
people that built me into who i am it
was really rewarding for me
love how humble he is that of course is
michael at his hollywood walk of fame
ceremony back in 2018 and can i just say
i also love that et canada has always
been on hand for all of his major career
milestones speaking of the global
superstar is set to kick off his
exclusive las vegas engagement on april
27th at resorts world which is the
perfect way to gear up for his world
tour
[Music]
this is so exciting what does it feel
like for you knowing that you have this
coming up i wanted to have eight shows
and the reason for having those eight
shows was it was a great way for me to
work out the new material not just
musically but
as an entertainer it was an incredible
way to market the record and have people
come from all over the world and be part
of understanding that i've made the
greatest music of my life
[Music]
i had friends calling me saying oh you
did it you're doing a residency well i'm
not doing the celine they build the
theater do 10 years i don't want to be
in vegas for 10 years i want to be in
vegas for four shows a week for two
weeks and then travel to 50 countries
all over the world because that is my
honor and my privilege it's to go all
over the world to different cultures and
different places to show up in your
backyard and to be tangible because
you've changed my life and so
i love the vegas thing but it's just a
little it's a little chewy bite and i
just love working all over the world so
if you can get tickets to that it's
going to be a blast
it will be
completely
[Music]
and i promise you we have no doubt that
michael will deliver fantastic
performances during his very limited las
vegas run but we won't tell him that yes
he has one rule when it comes to
performing my rule if you come and do
promo with me is that when i walk out
and i have a small group of people i
have you know the record exec who or the
you know that somebody who's taking care
of me from warner you know and maybe
someone who does glam or something right
but my my rule is
and you can ask my friend susan who
always always there with me she's one of
them
what's my rule sue's when i finish a tv
show don't say
don't say a word
[Music]
i don't want to hear a compliment i
don't want to hear that was amazing
because you know what else were you
going to say we're going to say hey
buble you suck
and you know what that has to be way
myself
better
i'm not gonna tell you who it is
but i did a tv show years ago
and it's a huge big time star tell me
everything and we did this thing where i
came out to the tv show and i sang my
song i did my thing and i was okay so i
finished and my people were and we just
sort of quietly did our job you know
very hockey player asked do your job put
your head down you know what i mean like
seriously it's a very canadian thing and
then this lady
got up
and she lip synced the thing
and she came off stage and this massive
group of
hangers on hers
popped champagne bottles open and like
like celebrated like they won something
and honestly i died i tried so very hard
not to lose it and no one loved her
enough no one loved her
where is their self-awareness
i need my wife at least six times a day
to say my you're so stupid
she's amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
et canada dominates digital we have more
twitter facebook instagram and youtube
followers than any other canadian
entertainment news show in the country
for exclusive celebrity access plus late
breaking news anytime anywhere
make sure to follow at et canada on your
favorite social media platform
i do not have time for this i do not
have time for you
that might be the most relatable tick
tock i've ever seen pretty sure every
parent on the planet has seen encanto at
least a hundred times glad to know that
michael understands the struggle but
did you know that one of the stars of
the oscar-winning animated film pursued
his music career because of mr buble
that's right colombian singer-songwriter
sebastian yatra
told morgan he owes a lot to the
canadian grammy winner
i collaborated with michael buble
last year we did a song called elita
also with gary barlow so i would love to
sit down with michael again we were
talking on what's up the other day and i
definitely want to want to sit down to
write with him and and do something else
because he's like one of my biggest
inspirations one of the reasons that i
actually started singing
well we will talk about michael's global
influence it is so incredible thanks for
watching everybody hope you love the
show we are going to leave you now with
the title track from michael's new album
higher be safe be well and we'll see you
next time
i think you know